- What would happen if
you would lose your job?
would you still be able to pay your bills
and provide for your family?
Just a couple of years ago,
for me, the answer would've been no.
I worked in consulting,
where I surely couldn't
complain about my salary.
If I would've lost that job,
I would've had a big problem
because that was by far
but most significant income stream.
Thankfully, over the last years
I was able to break free
from this dependency
on only relying on one stream of income.
So in this video, I
wanna give you an insight
into my journey, into what I did.
So, welcome to another coffee break,
here on my channel, Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich, and on my channel
I want to help you to become successful
in the first years of your career.
So in this video, I'm
first going to show you
the income streams that
I build for myself.
And second, some tips
how you can do similar things as well
that makes sense to you.
I recently read several articles,
the claim that an average millionaire
has about seven incomes
streams to his or her disposal.
So this motivated me to look
into my income streams as well,
and it turns out that I also have
seven income streams at the moment.
Unfortunately, I'm no millionaire.
And the truth is also that
it wasn't always like that,
this is only something that
I did over the last years.
So if we look back into 2019,
what my situation was then,
I was working in consulting
and 98% of my income was derived
from this consulting job.
Already at that time,
before I even started this YouTube channel
I had some online courses,
on topics like communications
and slide writing skills,
and I was earning a handful of extra bucks
by selling these courses.
But as you can see, I was still
heavily relying on my job.
Thankfully, the situation
improved already in 2020,
I was making about a quarter of my income
not from my full-time regular employment.
And in 2021, I managed derive,
almost two-third of my income
outside of my regular job.
And this is true, even though until today
I still work in a full-time job
and also with a healthy
development of my salary.
So how did I make this work for myself?
And for that, let's deep
dive into my income in 2021.
What's probably surprising is the income
that I derived from my full-time job.
So after having worked at McKinsey
for about six years in consulting,
I now work as chief revenue officer
for a Munich-based property
technology company.
But let's now also talk about
the other six income streams.
And I wanna start by the income streams
that are most closely related
to the YouTube channel.
Because fun fact,
whenever you tell someone
that you have a YouTube channel
the first question usually is,
okay, so how many subscribers do you have?
But then the second question is,
so how much do you earn with it, right?
So this is a question that
somehow seems to be very
close to the mind of
many people doing this.
Surely when I started my YouTube
channel in January, 2020,
I wouldn't even have believed
that this whole commercial
part is a big part of it all.
So I do hope that this alone
is also an inspiration to some of you
for people who are maybe are thinking
about starting similar projects like this.
And the first thing
that maybe comes to mind
when thinking about a YouTube channel,
is the YouTube ad revenue.
So whenever YouTube shows
an ad on your channel
the content creator
receives a revenue share
of the income that YouTube gets
from the company so all of the ad.
For larger channels,
this ad income alone can mean a six digit
or even seven digit annual income.
So what I'm sure is
still far away from that
it still provides me a solid 8% share
of the income that I'm making today.
Next is sponsorships.
So this is like the second
thing that comes to mind
if you think about
monetizing a YouTube channel.
So yes, I think it's more secret
that companies approach
creators, approach me,
and ask whether I would be
willing to collaborate with them
on any specific service or
product they're offering.
I can't tell you that I'm quite selective
on accepting these sponsorships.
So almost every day,
I now receive requests like this
but then for those companies
that you do accept as sponsors,
of course, you receive a
compensation for the collaboration
and these types of yields
amounted to 18% of my income last year.
Next is affiliate sales.
So also one of these
typical online business
revenue streams that exist out there
or this works is that for instance,
in my video description
you see different products,
different things,
services linked in there.
And whenever someone purchases
a product or a service
via one of these links,
I receive a certain revenue
share from these purchases.
But as you can see,
this income stream is
rather minor one for me.
I know that for some other creators,
this is actually one of
the largest income streams
for their social media platforms.
For myself, I didn't really figure out yet
the winning formula for all of this.
Next is online courses.
And here also include all
the other digital products
that I have, for instance,
CV templates or cover letter templates,
you find links to them
in the video description.
As you saw in the beginning,
this is actually the
additional revenue stream
I started with.
And of course, having a
platform like a YouTube channel
helps in selling more courses like that.
So, thanks to everyone who purchased
one of these courses in the past,
I do hope that they are
true value ad for you
and very much worth the money.
I'm actually currently working
on a major overhaul of my courses,
and I'm about to join
my new communications
and slide writing flagship course.
So, if you're interested in that,
there will be a link with a wait list
below in the video description.
Be free to sign up to be
informed once it goes live.
Next is business school lectures.
So, these are some of my online courses,
and maybe a little bit
also the YouTube channel
I got in contact with
several business schools
that I now conduct lectures for.
The most notable of these engagements
is the University of St. Gallen
where I teach on the full-time
and part-time MBA program
on professional development skills.
This is of course also compensated
and our contributes 2% of my income.
So, which is the last income
stream that is missing
which actually is my second
largest income stream
at the moment.
And this might surprise some of you
because I haven't talked about
this much here on my channel
but it's actually corporate trainings.
So over the last two years or so,
also via my online courses,
YouTube videos, and so on
I've been contacted by several companies
to provide corporate trainings
for some of the teams.
These topics also mainly
focus on communications,
slide writing and problem solving skills.
And this is now a good solid
extra income for myself
that provides about 19% of the
money that I made last year.
So this is the full picture
of my incomes stream.
What's maybe very worthwhile to notice
is what's not included here.
And these are all capital
gains dividends and so on.
So the past I already created a video
about my perspective on investing.
I will link it also somewhere above here.
If you watch that, you know
that I invest the majority
of the money that I do not
need to finance my life
into capital markets.
The majority of my money is in ETFs
that automatically reinvest the dividends
which is why I do not have
any active income from that.
Now that you've seen the full picture
I would be interested in
your perspective as well.
Does all of this surprise you?
Did you already build
some extra income streams
besides your full-time job as well?
Because now I wanna share
some more general tips
on what you could do as well
to build some additional income streams
and potentially get a bit more independent
from your regular full-time job.
And the first idea
is the concept of the
surface area of luck,
because surely, it takes some
luck to something like this,
some YouTube channel, for instance.
Surely I was the lucky
that several of my videos got picked up
by the YouTube algorithm
shown to many people like you
and they have a contributing to the growth
of my channel and they
have also contributing
to many of the income streams.
But what most definitely
is not winning to energy
is just to sit at home at your desk
and wait for your lucky moment
that something magical happens
and suddenly out of nothing,
good things come to you.
I mean, this is not how it works.
Instead, you should pursue things
that widen your surface area,
widen the possibilities
that something lucky
like this might happen to you.
Are you the photography?
That's great develop and own your skills.
Maybe into a very a specific sport.
Pursue that.
What's important though,
is to not expect that from any
of these patients activities
from yours or day one, you
will already make money.
I would never have thought
when I started this YouTube channel
that now almost 20% of my income
would come from delivering
corporate training sessions.
Increase your surface area of luck
and good things will
happen to you as well.
Second, think about the time
that you systematically
waste during your week.
Surely there's no problem.
And occasionally also
relaxing watching a TV series,
Netflix, gaming or whatever
pushes your buttons.
Though, what might
potentially be problematic
is if you make it a habit of yours
that every single evening
say after 7:00 P.M.
you do all these things
consistently every single day.
I am convinced that all your life
will look like in five years
will very much be determined
by this time that you
invest in your evenings
in your spare hours whether
you value your own time
and make it count do to some extent
something productive with it or not.
And third, and this might be a hard truth
for some of us to swallow.
So I will surely not in a position,
not able to do all these things,
invest all the time
that I'm investing today
to build all these things
while I was still working in Consulting.
The job was just too demanding.
Every day during the work week
I was working very late hours.
On the weekend I was just
tired most of the time
and just wouldn't have had the clear head
just of thinking about things like this.
So while I think it's
very valid and for sure,
for me it was us the right decision.
To any of you in you
20's or also early 30's
pick such a high-paced career
that really provides you
with lots of learnings.
At some point, everyone needs to ask
his or herself this question,
whether picking up a job
with maybe a bit more
regular working hours
wouldn't be a good idea
not only for family, which is of course,
a big dimension in this all
decision process as well,
but also just to have the flexibility
to pursue some extra
opportunities like this.
So these are just my sense on the topics.
I'm surely not saying and recommending
that everyone should
start a YouTube channel,
but do think that there
are many other ways
to make something productive
with some hobbies and skills of yours.
But now again, let me
know in your comments,
what is your perspective?
Are you already building
something like this?
How has your journey been looking like?
I trust this might be very inspirational
and maybe also to some of
the more junior people here
in the audience.
As always, if you took any
value out of this video at all,
please destroy the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe and turn
on the notification bell
to stay up-to-date on all my content.
Big, big, thanks to all
the members of the channel
and for your support.
This is very much appreciated.
My name is Heinrich
I'm the creator of this channel.
I release new videos
every single Saturday.
So looking forward to
stay in touch with you.
All the best of you until next week.
Bye-bye.